let's do some examples figuring out the
magnitude of a vector if we're just
given some information about it so one
of the simplest cases would be well lyft
is told us the actual components of the
vector so if they said vector a is equal
to let's say five comma negative three
this means that it's X component is
positive five its Y component is
negative three well if we have this then
the magnitude of a the magnitude of a is
just going to be and this really just
comes from the distance formula which
just comes from the Pythagorean theorem
the magnitude of a is just going to be
the square root of the X component
squared so let me do that in a different
color so the square root of the X
component squared so five squared plus
the Y component squared so plus negative
three squared and this is going to be
equal to the square root of 25 25 plus
nine plus nine which is equal to the
square root of 34 which is equal to the
square root of 34 and if you want to
think about this visually this is very
easy to do just looking at the actual
components but if you want to make sense
of this Y this is essentially just the
Pythagorean theorem we could draw out a
quick coordinate axis right over here so
that's our Y axis this is our let's see
I have a Y component of negative three
so let's see that is our actually let me
try to draw it a little bit different
let me draw it like this that is our x
axis and we see it's X component is
positive five so one two three four five
that's five there and it's Y component
it's negative three so one two three and
so this is negative three and so we can
draw this vector with just with its
initial point remember we can always
shift around a vector as long as we
don't change its magnitude in two
direction we can start at the origin and
make it go five in the
x-direction and negative 3 in the
y-direction and so it's terminal point
will be right over there at the point 5
comma negative 3 and so the vector the
vector will look like this and if we
want to figure out the magnitude that's
just the length of this line and what we
can do is just set up a right triangle
where our change our change in Y is this
negative 3 right over here that is our
change in Y and our change in X is this
positive 5 is that positive 5 and so
this is a right triangle five squared
plus you could just view the absolute
value of the sign just three so five
squared plus three squared is going to
be the hypotenuse squared
come straight out of the Pythagorean
theorem